one of my mentors ron bruder um
you know taught me what mentorship was
really all about
i met him professionally i was
introduced to him he's
very accomplished very successful much
you know many years my senior
very wise we got along and you know a
week or two later i
i had a question that i thought he might
be able to help me with and i called him
and he
took my call i only met him once and
they took my call again
and then we met for lunch he just kept
saying yes
and he became my mentor you know
and i remember us at his house one day
and i was getting
i was leaving and i put my arm around
him and i used the m word for the very
first time i said
i love that you're my mentor and he said
something to me that it i didn't expect
he said and i love that you're mine
and that's when i realized a mentor
relationship is is more like a
friendship you know
you can't just walk up to a random
person and say will you be my mentor of
course
just like you can't walk up to a random
person and say will you be my friend
that's not how it works
mentor relationships evolve
because a mentor always has time for you
they see something in you for some
reason that they make time for you
and they learn as much as they
as much as they teach yeah they come
into it because they
they learn i never knew that ron was
getting something from our time together
i thought he was just doing me favors
because he was an amazing guy
um and a mentor relationship is it's a
mentor mentor relationship
so this whole idea of like you're
assigned to be someone's mentor
like ah maybe that could work well that
seems again going back to sort of a
transactional like
transaction you know you have to have
mentors and you have to seek them out
yeah i remember when i was junior
looking for a job you know people say
what are you looking for
and my standard answer in every
interview as an entry-level
you know idiot was uh that's the theme
in my in my
career uh i'm just a more senior idiot
now yeah
um uh when they say what are you looking
for
my answer was always the same i said
what i'm looking for is probably
akin to looking for love but i'm looking
for a mentor
and every job that i was looking for i
was
i was more concerned about the people i
would work for
than i was how much they would pay me or
whether the account was high profile or
low profile
and so i took jobs with like accounts
that nobody ever heard of
uh because i didn't care i cared about
the people who's gonna work i wanted to
work with really smart amazing people
who would teach me and help me grow yeah
and that's one of the reasons
i got to work with some of these
wonderful people yeah